tutti io mi chiamo carla sono originarie
dalla libia sono arrivata in italia nel
primo periodo qua in italia è stato un
po difficile per me ma dopo ho scoperto
l'atletica leggera
mia mamma già era solito a mandarmi a
fare le commissioni di là prendermi il
pane ma già corre velocissima a prendere
le uova per me erano come delle piccole
garette
andavo correvo perché mi faceva stare
bene e volevo battere sempre il mio
record
giovanna prendi il cronometro con tamil
tempo
ovviamente andava sempre di corsa il mio
primo approccio con la corsa fu grazie
alla scuola ma soprattutto grazie alla
corsa campestre
dove vinse il mio primo titolo italiano
nel 2006
la corsa mi rendeva veramente felice
mi lega i così tanto la corsa anche per
il fatto che potevo stare fuori casa
potevo viaggiare potevo prendere un
treno per me era bellissimo quindi così
mi avvicinai tantissimo alla corsa e poi
le ore di educazione fisica l'erede di
occasioni fisica furono il mio primo
il primo mezzo di comunicazione con i
miei compagni
immaginatevi di discorsi loro
edificazione fisica era la mia ora
preferita perché era l'unico modo per
comunicare quindi lo sport mi ha aiutato
a iniziare a parlare l'italiano perché
quando sono arrivata quando sapevo
neanche una parola trame l'ora
dell'azione fisica di mi rendeva felice
perché riuscivo a scambiarmi due sorrisi
o due chiacchiere con i miei compagni
dopo diversi problemi familiari
diciamo sono rinata sono decisamente
rinata
letteralmente rinata
il madron il matrimonio imposto
l'allontanamento di casa
il ritorno in italia
il como
sì il coma e poi la rinascita
e li capi veramente il valore della vita
dopo la mia rinascita ha un solo ed
unico obiettivo correre e far correre
gli altri perché questo mi ha fatto
capire quanto è veramente importante la
corsa
la cosa mi aveva veramente salvata
sono questi gli eventi che mi hanno
portata a diventare oltre con a rainer
una croce runner
due anni fa
ho dato vita a una crew che si chiama
flyers academy sono delle ragazze
diversi tra loro tra loro ma accomunati
da un solo da una sola cosa che la corsa
che ci troviamo quasi tutti i giorni a
correre nelle strade di milano
ciò che cerco di trasmettere attraverso
la corsa
non so come spiegarvelo cioè tutte le
persone sanno correre
tutti sanno farlo e immaginatevi quanto
è difficile per me insegnare la corsa
infatti non è quello che voglio fare un
obiettivo non è quello di insegnare alle
persone a correre perchè lo sanno fare
tutti ma insegnare quello che si può
superare attraverso la corsa quello che
a me evitato ad affrontare così grandi
problemi attraverso la corsa come volete
grazie alla corsa che sono di nathan
ciò che è capace la corsa all azione
semplicemente della corsa a farci
superare anche perché la corsa è
un'azione che si ripete più volte
ti obbliga a pensare ed è per questo che
a volte le persone dicono no non c'ho
voglia è mai e dopo un po mi annoio
no perché tu non puoi pensare
e per questo che non vuoi andare a
correre
invece la corsa ci obbliga a pensare ci
obbliga ad affrontare i nostri problemi
e ciò che non vogliamo mai fare
perché per me la corsa è una terapia
è qualcosa che ci fa star bene quindi
perché non parla a volte per me più
correre correre più facile correre con i
ragazzi del playmore che con tutti voi
pensa nel corso degli anni ho coltivato
a diverse amicizie
una è quella di matteo
diverse amicizie che mi hanno insegnato
davvero tanto apprezzare anche le
piccole cose matteo è un ragazzo extra
gilet matteo insieme a me cambia
completamente
matteo non ha orari non sa cosa e lui
vive vive la giornata è un ragazzo
carico a mille
lui si carica e va diviso tale giornata
carichissimo non si ferma mai matteo
aspetta fermati no no lui vive così è
una potenza con matteo deciso di
fare un viaggio abbiamo organizzato un
viaggio per farlo stare bene per far
divertire lui invece mi sbagliavo perché
alla fine di quel viaggio sono tornato a
stando bene io e matteo che aveva
aiutato me e quindi dal io ho cambiato
in modo di vedere le cose che tante
volte pensiamo noi di aiutare gli altri
quando sono gli altri ad aiutare noi
tante volte quando si parla della corsa
soprattutto le donne
quando si parla di sport le donne e
soprattutto di sport e della corsa la
donna si sottovalutano io non ce la
faccio no ma è difficilissimo ma non ce
la farò mai
come spesso 16 andiamo a fare la mezza
maratona gli uomini vabbè dai due
chiacchiere il massimo e camminiamo i
maschi non ci fermiamo la donna parte
già tanti non ce la fa romani non ce la
farò due settimane fa feci fare una
ragazza a un test di 30 minuti è la
stessa storia nylon ma non ce la farò
mai dai non riuscirò a fare ma senza 30
minuti senza fermarci si tenta mente
senza fermarsi dai che ci vuoi fare e
grazie al mio aiuto è al suo aiuto alla
sua forza di volontà è riuscita a
superare è riuscita a fare trenta minuti
senza mai fermarsi è riuscita ad andare
oltre i propri limiti questo ci fa
capire quanto a volte il primo passo ci
fa andare oltre il primo pasto si
sblocca e perciò scioglietevi e andiamo
scarpe pantaloncini e una maglietta e
termica perché fa un po freddo e andiamo
ancora via spettatore del team a me
quindi ci vediamo al primo